I mean, it is very much, I know we were talking about the NBA before we started recording, but
it does. I mean, think of how Nathaniel, you were just talking about there's like I can anticipate
the move before he does it, and then you talk about like we're, you know, we're finding a catch, like I
agree with you, we're this, to me, is very much, very similar to playing sports and developing a feel
for the team, right? Like how the team dynamic works and how you play off of each other and I mean, which
is interesting insofar as there aren't, you know, rules or a court or any of those sort of obvious
things, but nevertheless the dynamics are still very, very similar, I think, and there could be phases like
I could anticipate the the moves one because I had gone through it, and then I'm basically, I'm
effectively watching the tape, right? Oh, I see how you know Nate got open for that three on that particular
play, like whereas, but like during the game it just happened, but but yeah, or it's like Nate's
fucking hogging the ball again, right? Yeah, but I think I do think that, you know, the more we
practice this, you know, the more we're going to be able to anticipate each other's moves and hopefully
not just like there goes John again with his blah blah blah, right? But it's more like all right, he's
gonna, you know, he's gonna put like make this move, which means I'm gonna get open to this spot
right? And that that'll be where I think it probably gets really fun. Yeah, I've been on so
I've been on team Carmelo is the title of the podcast. Yeah, quick Carmelo, I've been Carmelo
ball. I've seen that jab step before. I know it just ends up in a in a pull-up. Oh, we lost again, sorry
team, that's where so like, you know, you got your mellow, I got my AI, and and Nathaniel was the Pippin man
you know, he's great, so working off of both of us, you know, I'll be Pippin. Yeah, I'll be Pippin
I've been known to have a headache here and there. Well, if he's Pippin and neither of us is Jordan
then he might be the best player I was just gonna say. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, but it's also there there's
there is something to that insofar as like, you know, in terms of an external project, you clearly have
one you're writing your dissertation on this sort of new materialist stuff and and broad and you know
the way that the Butler uptake whatever I'm doing this style thing and I mean I, when I'm listening to
us I'm like I hear me smearing that across everything that we're saying. Nathaniel isn't I mean even
though you're working on projects it's not directly related to this like you're actually interested much
more in just playing whereas you know we do have uh deliverables or outcomes that uh that we're working
through you know so so it makes sense that you would be more of the Pippin and I I think and I think we
all sort of have sufficient understanding of each other's sensibilities so that we can kind of cross
over and because I I not that I have as as rigorous of an understanding of the loses as either of you do
but like I think I know that most of the movements at least at a general level so I can kind of well
it's not like predicting and then getting like a counterpoint but like I can I can just sort of see
the picture, um, I don't know, in a little more of a precise way. It did occur to me in going through
and annotating that we've actually written essays, like each of these episodes has at least one or two
essays in them that if you because I I found myself drawn to like a point that I would make I
after I listened to it I'm like well yeah but I'd want to add this in, right? Like I'd want to add this
clarify. Like there was one point where we were talking about students and you were you used the
term of them being dutiful, like honors college students, and that's what academia produces and we
all sort of agreed and then we moved on and I was like but I would want to say the same thing about
teachers too, right? That that teachers in academia or have the same kind of dutiful honors college
mentality that it's it's been super evident to me in the context of the coronavirus, um, where I I've
been kind of staggered by I'm like guys we're the adults in the room like we can make the choices
and decisions about what but whatever but that's something that I wanted to like add back into that
conversation but then I was like well you know, um, that would turn it into an essay and this is this
really is a these are frameworks for uh for essays or or maybe a book or whatever. I mean that I mean
it's an interesting idea to think like this could actually go in a different direction than the one
that we're intending here, which is we could figure out a way of getting this on paper and making it a uh
you know triple author whatever, right? Like yeah by slowing it down a little bit and
unpacking some of the things a little bit, you know, you're right about the it should be targeted at
the lifers not just the students who go and get other jobs but the the lifelong academics are the real
dutiful that's that's kind of was more the target I think right right yeah right because it used to be I
mean maybe at one point back in the 60s or 70s academia attracted actually like creative artistic
sort of against the grain type people and then somewhere along the way there I think it started
attracting just rule followers you know because you follow the rules then you get the grades and then
that's what you're good at so you stick at but the number of the number of faculty who believe in
grades I mean I'll let me just say that that's that's been a bugbear of mine for a long time like
that they believe in the value of grades I mean I remember when we did that when we went to the
shutdown and several of my colleagues were like so what are you doing what are you doing I was like
well I gave them all A's and then we're going to figure out they're like you gave them all like it
was this scandalous thing and subsequently I never heard of anyone else who did that and I was like well
it's a goddamn pandemic like everything else is in flux like yeah I'm not going to create
additional stress for them around the grade like you even give the the lazy fucker I'm like yeah of
course I mean come on this is not and I you know you start realizing the extent to which teachers
especially are so invested in their ability to give grades and it's like in their function of of
establishing a hierarchy to which I you know I mean you guys have heard me rant about like I I love the
function of grades within the context of the semester in the class but subsequent to that like I don't give
a fuck defeat a social order and make it easier easier for some middle management person to filter
people like I don't I have no interest in that um and I really really don't do not understand my
colleagues all of whom have a strong investment in that outcome a lot of grad students too have the same
thing I don't I don't have any interest in wielding power over these students which people do have that
I mean I think for a lot of profs it's not the desire to to wield power it's the sort of integrity
that I'm not giving you this grade you've earned it and then there's the anxiety of correctly
interpreting what has been earned but what is it I mean that's like the real duty comes in you're not
the prick cop that likes to show off their power I mean like that does happen don't get me wrong I've
seen that but what is the integrity that's being protect being protected by that like what are they
protecting like the the notion of the sanctity of knowledge or something I mean what what is being
protected by like well you're just you're protecting yourself first and foremost because you're you're
protecting yourself against the the threat of the institution not taking you seriously you know
or the threat of the students not taking you seriously so if you have that barrier you know you're
putting a wall between you and them I don't know it always just seems self-serving to me
but I would I mean that's where I mean I made the decision about two years ago in my own head and
I mean in conversation with others but I made a personal decision is that like I'm just giving all A's for
the rest of my career right like I'm just doing that now I'm not going to announce that and I'm not
saying it in the class like I still see a function especially in undergrad classes you know I mean I've said
grad classes for years at the beginning like you just show up you've got an A right like but I mean
but for undergrads I understand the function during the course of the semester but after the semester is
done why would I care to distinguish a C student from an A student it doesn't seem to me to have any
value in learning I mean the only function is a social one which it makes it like I said it makes
it easier for someone else to uh you know tax on to hierarchize people and to admit them to graduate
school or admit them to a job or whatever thing and I'm like I don't see I don't see that as my job
um I mean again I think the integrity of some kind like the grade represents the worth of the student as
they manifested it in this class so there can be you know plenty of accounting for contingencies that
are like well you know they weren't a good student and now they are they were a good student and they
you know couldn't show up for this class or they were just lazy for this one and but that whatever
it is that grade represents the worth of that student's combination of effort and talent in that
class and that's I think that's what I mean the integrity is all about you know the clarity of
representation because that that grade stands in for something higher and more important you know
whether yeah I mean that's where the distinction between for me the distinction between the grades
during the semester and the final grade there's no correlation between the two of them for me because
the final grade is just a I mean I don't see them again right it's it's just a judgment that I'm
placing on their record, uh, it has no but this is the difference is I don't think most, because it has
that that, um, function of representation. I don't think that that most profs look at grades as
pedagogical in the way that you do. Like, it is a judgment and the only thing you can do is judge
it more or less correctly but for you you're like, you know, the work that you do, like the grade that I give
your work isn't primarily induced by how good I think it is, it's about how I think you're going
to respond. That's entirely, yeah, yeah, but that's, well, for a lot of people that's pretty radical
right? I mean, like, I would say you're the only one that I know that's so
baldly advocates for that. I mean, I would simply say that's it's saying grades are rhetorical like I
mean in my terminology that's all I'm saying and and they all are like all grades are rhetorical the
question is where do they function into what purpose, which is where for me the final grade functions
differently for a different purpose than the grades during the course of the semester.
Yeah, but I I just think that most profs see themselves as part teacher and part judge and I
think that you see yourself as all teacher. Yeah, right. We we can choose not to be a gatekeeper.
The thing is that class especially like uh 101 102, it's designed structurally to be a gatekeeping
mechanism. You can you can choose not to do that though by giving everybody an A so that's been kind
of my my approach maybe I got that from you John I don't know I think I probably would have done that
anyway. Again, that's not I'm not saying that's like the best way to do it because I think that's for me
at least it's also self-serving like it's just easier for me to deal with it that way I'm not
getting complaints from students. You don't get great complaints that's that kind of thing so again I
was saying the other side was self-serving so is mine. My reasons are also but you know I'm not
hurting anyone I'm not hurting anyone's careers right? Like when I when I first started doing it I
experienced a lot of difficulty giving what I sort of thought of as the C student da right? Like it was
that was hard and I was like ah that just doesn't seem it just doesn't seem right and then I I but
I finally was like why am I spending so much time obsessing about the bad students and worrying about
how it's unfair to the good students because of the bad you know like and I was just like why don't
just give them all A's and I I will say like even though it's difficult to do at first and for the first
couple of semesters that I did it it was experientially hard for me to do it subsequently it's like it's
the best thing I've ever done for for me in that case and I mean I teach few enough undergraduate
classes that that word hasn't gotten around among them so they in fact I still see like the they'll
tell me the stuff that's on the rate my professor or whatever that's like he grades really hard and his
exams are really hard and I like yeah like that's how in the course of the semester when I'm teaching
you and you're learning and we're thinking together I want that uh uh you know sense of
you have to be rigorous in order to do well in this class and then unbeknownst to you
the end of it you're all going to get the same prize you know and the ones who worked the hardest and
even the ones who fucked off and didn't care and sat in the back room stoned you know right
right, yeah, that's that's sort of a good approach. It's an interesting I'll say that it does. I mean
a lot depends your capacity to mobilize that pedagogically has a lot to do with where you are
absolutely you are in your career like I I can't do that because my department there are only seven of
us and you know you're likely to teach the same students over and over again like that word gets
out really quickly now so I have like within that um so like I don't give always you know like I'm
more or less within the norms of of everyone else but like ultimately the decisions that I make for my
students is like what how are you going to respond to this right and right right and I mean I certainly
don't have my approach down pat I mean I've only taught you know uh I don't even know how many
total students 300 400 somewhere in there but I and it it's clearly contingent on the class as well
like the approach how lax you can be how authoritative you can be and how it like succeeds or fails depending
on that dynamic like last semester right before the pandemic uh hit I was doing the kind of hands-off
like I basically told them up front they were gonna succeed in the class I that was the first
time I did that and I don't think that's the way to go at least for for someone in my position because
it right it was just like you know people were sort of disengaged I think right away and even I was
disengaged with the material at that point and it was sort of a disaster of a class but right before
that the semester before that I was almost the same approach. It's just I, I wasn't quite as explicit
with it. And those were two of the best classes I've ever taught, like in terms of engagement
and responsiveness and that sort of thing. So it's like it's very, uh, sort of a you, you can be, it's
a really thin line between the success of that approach and then it's it's potential failure. I agree
and I think you guys are both right. I mean, and one of the things for me that's very very clear is
that I'm not doing some content, I'm not acting as to universalize the predicates of my action, right.
I'm not, I don't think that it would work in every case. I don't think that it would work for other
people. I don't think, I mean I really really don't. And, and you're quite right if I was in a smaller
institution or if I was younger, right? Like I mean what for me it's one of the things I've had this a
couple of times in my career where I'm like I don't think there's surveillance so I don't but I don't
really know and I'm just gonna and I'm just gonna act as if there's not until something bumps up against
me, you know what I mean? And it's like I don't know that there's oversight. I don't know who it
would be. I don't know how it would work but it's possible that at some point people start someone
starts noticing, like all of Muckelbauer's classes are A's and there's some red flag on a computer
system or something and I mean maybe it trickles down to me and in two years I have a talking to or
something. I mean I, I, I don't, I don't know how it's going to play out but I'm going to act as if
there because I don't actually encounter the surveillance and you know it's the Foucault
point right? Like I do feel as if a lot of people have internal a lot of especially grad students
TA's when they're teaching they've internalized the hypothetical possibility that there's someone
in that center tower, you know, surveilling them so that you don't actually have to have someone in
the center tower and I'm like hey guys how about act as if no one's in the central tower for a little
while until someone says oh by the way you can't do that in your classroom you know yeah yeah again
I mean given if you have a sort of pedagogically motivated I'm not saying like oh just teach naked
or something. I mean it's not like it's not a question of just being silly right it's it's a
question that like if you're committed to a some sort of pedagogical orientation don't worry about
the idea that prospectively there is someone surveilling you uh um because look I and I've had this I I
I remember one specific tenure meeting where people were really tearing up this particular person
because of uh really low um scores in a class in which the teacher had really created a kind of
unusual experiment with with grades and how they worked and I mean I remember like making the
argument insistently and adamantly as you can imagine me doing of like I'm going to stand up for
the possibility for the for the uh pedagogical failure as you know in other words trying some
shit experimentation that falls apart and doesn't work like I'm going to go to bat for yeah for
someone who tries that you know and yeah it didn't work but here's what you don't see he did he didn't
continue doing it class after class after class like he tried something interesting he had a rationale
for doing it it it did not work like my contingency class that we talked about a couple of episodes
ago it it didn't work and like I again I I will just go to the mat for that's what a teacher does
right? A teacher has to be able to do things that just don't work sometimes
yeah I mean there's something interesting if not explicitly ethical about like engaging a dissonant
orientation towards the institution and those kind of that that panopticon right? I mean like
for me again maybe it's just a rationalization of the approach but when I give somebody a B or an A
that could have gotten a C or a D or even potentially failed, like when I make that move
I feel like I am like I don't have to be the one to set them on that path of failure like if they're
gonna if they're gonna act if they're gonna behave the way they did in my class they're probably gonna do it
again. That's right. And someone someone's gonna fail them down the line. I don't see myself as having to
take that position where I set someone down and they fail out of school. Again you could think I'm
sure there's the you could exercise the complete opposite view and make it you know an interesting
case but that's the way I've been sort of thinking and that's where Nathaniel is I think so spot on
which is if you end up like right now you're at a ginormous state institution where you can be kind
of invisible but when you're one of seven faculty and and you have a very limited number of students
that take you multiple times it's a lot harder for that not to be for them not to immediately become
aware of that situation and whether they address that. Yeah, you know, who knows? Correct, I mean, the
advantage of that for me is that because I I know my students way better and I have, you know, I'm
obviously never totally right about this, but I have a much better sense of how they're going to respond
to this or that grade and yeah, you know, I know how close I can get to a breaking point to make someone
try to strive better and I know, you know, like when I'm just like the grades low enough that they're just
going to give up or whatever else I mean. Yep, yep. Isn't it cool when you're wrong? I I find, you know,
I've been doing this for 25 years or so and I always just am fascinated when I'm wrong about
it where I like I really feel like I know, you know, I tried to get this one girl to stop taking
my courses after the first year she took me and then freaking two more courses later I see her on
my roster I'm like what do I have to do you get it you get a d two semesters in a row
but I think that's cool, right? I mean, I know, but it was it showed me something and like
you know, she came to my office hours all the time and worked on stuff and I mean you could
make the argument that I'm just like enabling students to do poorly but that would be like
the worst case scenario of the version that I'm doing but okay I mean but here's the thing is
I mean I feel like what's wrong with that? Like what's wrong? Like, you know, I mean I don't care but
I mean it really for me it relates back to this idea that it's a it's it's erroneous to think that
25 people could just sign up for my class and all equally learn from me and I learned, you know, like
that's an erroneous assumption that is a that is again there are institutional structures financial
reasons etc. why you have to do that at the same time like it's so therefore like there's going to be
a certain number of people who come into the class who just aren't it's not going to click right and
that's where I agree with you that I don't feel like I'm going to be the policeman who's going to
tell them they can't they can't advance or matriculate to the next level because I don't really care
because I don't deal with them at the next level uh yeah, you know, uh, if they ask me to write a letter
of recommendation for graduate school I have a different, you know, I have a different take on that you
know, like a totally mediocre student who asked me to do that I'll say you might want to find someone
who can write a stronger letter, you know, the you're right you're both right the relative
anonymity at at uh South Carolina is kind of key for that because yeah I would I don't even I can't
even really put myself in Nathaniel's shoes in that context because I'm just so used to the large
university the state school kind of thing yeah I think it was a total shock for me like realizing
that I had, you know, not just students, you know, from one term to the next but like students I would
have, you know, two or three years later and they've taken, you know, all these courses from my colleagues
and multiple of them so the kind of intimacy and like everyone gets a sense for everyone's classes and
they, you know, so do you have those do you have conversations? Because I only get this very sporadically
and occasionally where I find that I'm having conversations with other faculty through their
students do you? Yeah? Oh yeah, do that. Yeah, it's and and that part is usually a lot of fun like
the very first class that I taught was um effectively a second year course that I had kind of built off of
USC's 102 just like I I taught, you know, um uh Jeff Walker's, um rhetorical analysis book and we're just
going through the concepts and doing a research paper out from that and I'm teaching um ethos and I had
like two students like raise their hand and sort of ask like why are we paying so much attention to the
author like what about Barth and the death of the author and I was just like holy this is awesome I
can't believe you asked me about this right and it's because you know they had both taken this other
second level course uh on critical like introduction to critical theory you know, like the the woman that
teaches it my colleague calls it baby theory but like the one concept that they latch on to is death of
the author yeah yeah and so then like I just ended up having this whole side like like I said bracket
those questions I gave him like a 30 second response to bracket those questions and we'll
talk later and then I got to have this whole thing about you know the way we're going to think about
ethos more in terms of an author function and we're taking a Foucauldian turn toward it and they both took
like my class uh where we I taught Foucault and I taught Barth and Foucault back to back and um
so that I mean like when it works out like that um or like when I taught that I took another class
I'm teaching like you know Butler and Foucault and they're also taking a queer theory course at the
Same time, you know, that kind of and I'm having this intermediary conversation with my colleagues, it's
It's a lot of fun.
Okay, let's talk about God. All right. 19. 19.
Thus the life of God and divine cognition may well be spoken of as a
disporting of love with itself, but this idea sinks into mere edification and even
insipidity if it lacks the seriousness, the suffering, the patience, and the labor of the negative.
I, I imagine Nate just loves that sentence. Yeah, you won't. Yeah, the Nietzsche in you is not gonna like
that, John. Like, I just don't like seriousness all that much. I like how Russian it sounds. I know he's
German, but it sounds so Russian, you know? Right, right. Because for me, one of the biggest draws
towards Nietzsche when I was 16, I mean when I didn't understand philosophy at all and was just reading this
stuff was, was precisely like kill the spirit of gravity, right? That's that sort of recurring message
in The Gay Science specifically, which is still my book, like for, for me, that's the Nietzsche book. The
Gay Science. And I mean that was it was kill the spirit of gravity. Like why, why seriousness is the
tone or the necessary tone for thinking in philosophy is and it was just this eye-opener this for me it was just
just like splash of cold water in the face of like wait why is seriousness yeah the tone through which
thinking is supposed to go why isn't it laugh why isn't it laughter and no i totally get that i mean
just real quick before but like the the seriousness of someone like Hegel for me is is not quite the same
as like uh Bacons or cons or whatever for me Hegel's seriousness is sort of more tragic it's the that's
why i said it was it sounded russian because like Dostoevsky's seriousness it's about like
misery and pain it's not just about like formalism like in itself you know what i mean so yeah again
we can keep we can get back to that but it's but that question of the tragic is a big i mean that's
an important one right like so for instance that's that's Nietzsche's whole thing about the Greeks
right in Greek tragedy is it's precisely the the suffering that they've learned how to affirm
right that this is not a this is not an escape from it it's kind of an immersion in in suffering
so that sense of tragedy is really really important for him in terms of what he what he will call
life affirming yeah i think it's important to point out here that like this this suffering
patience, labor of the negative, you know, it doesn't have to be the disposition of the human to this
thing it is just the undergoing of the of of the um playing out of spirit itself which is also like
kind of greek and in terms of you know the wisdom of silenus like life itself is suffering you know the
layer on top of it that Nietzsche adds is and your response doesn't have to be suffering right like
you can affirm that suffering and Hegel saying affirm that suffering too but just much more in a
representational like take on the suffering that you know the like take on the burden of of playing
out the suffering that is life
But by the way I mean this is just this is an aside maybe and I mean it comes up here but this is
something that you've brought up indirectly a couple times of the critique of Hegel's essentialism that's
that's not a critique that I have at all like not at all like this is a version of essentialism that to
me is you know like what essentialism should be if if you're going to use the terminology of essence
because it's it's right I mean here clearly the problem well I'm already getting into talking
about it so it turns out not to be an aside but I mean um you know his critique is precisely of a
static notion of essence right like is essence that is sort of self self-present um and right and it's
that essence needs to be sort of put into motion uh that's yeah what he's calling form like the essence has to be
or the motion itself has to be that new the new essence um and so that's right to me
to call it an essentialism is just to it's just to kind of fetishize the word essentialism as a bad
thing it's not it's like right you know there's this is people it's it's sort of the same thing like the the kind
of um lazy critiques of Derrida who take the their everything is a text line and just say he's a construct like
a linguistic constructionist or whatever it's the same people do that with idealism too or in Hegel's version
they're like well it everything comes under this uh everything is appropriated under subjectivity
under this master subject and it's like well I mean sure under a certain extremely reductive reading
but everything falls apart under subjectivity right it's not everything is not collected um but yeah
you're right the essence here is the essence is the concept for Hegel or it's some form of mediation
which is uh, you know, not what the immediate substance or pure self-intuition people are
positive it has, like, the Spinoza, it has to be, yeah, it has to be mobile now, you know, whether or not
that's a good reading of Spinoza is in fact actually, it's a, it's an important question, right? Because
it relates back to something that's a recurring thing is there's this, for me, what's odd about Hegel is
his constant criticism of other directions as being not enough or not going the right way or whatever, and
it would seem to be like that that is precisely the thing that should be disabled in his thinking.
you would think so, you would think so, and and yet at the same time, like, like, these people are so
reflexive Žižek is taking after him in some ways and he's so critical of basically everybody he there's
a very select few that Hegel's like they kind of got it and everyone else or that that Žižek is like
they kind of got it everyone else he's like they missed this they missed this crucial thing it's
like it's so uh, it's both kind of arrogant and so cruel that what he does to to certain people
where he's like your entire project missed the the whole point of of this of this paradigm or this this
this mode of thinking and i found that i i haven't read enough Žižek to comment on this but i found that
in Habermas and it's it's honestly one of the reasons that i i just can't read Habermas well
like i just i'm angry all of the time when i read Habermas because in the Philosophical Discourses of
Modernity you know he has like a chapter on Foucault a chapter on Derrida you know he's got a chapter on
these various folks and the upshot of each one of them is because of you know this decision that the
thinker made he's unable to get to communicative rationality which to me is just it's like he's unable to get to
me you know and so so the result is that everyone else in the world is just a failed version of me
right like and i i do kind of see that here like i see that move is like everything else is just an
inadequate uh, a version of my philosophy which by the way my philosophy should should be about how
nothing is ever adequate and so therefore you know nothing is ever a failure
you're right no you're you're absolutely right but i think the the the crucial distinction between
someone like Hegel and Habermas or Žižek and Habermas is that both Žižek and Hegel kind of know that
they're making that move and that's part that's what they're diagnosing is sort of the impossibility
of not making that move yeah maybe maybe i'm not sold yet on your Žižekian version of Hegel
here's what i right here's what i mean here's what i'm i'm sold on that as a viable and interesting
reading of Hegel i'm not sold on it because Hegel doesn't seem to me to be entirely self-conscious
here of you know making making moves right right in that way like again the contemporary variations
whether it's Malibu or Žižek might be and i and i'm not going to say that's a bad reading or a good
reading of Hegel i mean i see how that right it's more interesting but it's a reading to me right yeah
it does seem to me like an intervention into the thing where uh, and again distinguishing between
an intervention into it and the thing itself is a problem um, but but i don't right i don't get that
level of like look i recognize that what i'm doing here is a moment in the the uh, revelation of
spirit i don't get any sense of that you know uh, in Hegel well i mean but it's again i feel i don't
know because it is so diagnostic and and and kind of and reflexive the way that it turns over its own
oppositions and then relates itself to the the targets like the way he resolves you know resolves
certain points is is convoluted to the point where you know there's there's no easy way out
of this system there's no easy way out of the dialectic i totally agree with that i i do think
there is a level of like i'm culpable here as well it's not like he comes out and says that he's not
like well i'm also a victim of this thing and just as these people are because he wants to be on
top of this the impulse to be on top of the system is still there again it might be Malibu
speaking through me or Žižek but like that transcendentalist tendency is what they foreground
as like part of the system whereas like you're talking about Habermas it's all implicit in Habermas
he doesn't recognize that in himself that he's making these kind of appropriative or cutting
gestures that's right but i'm not sold that Hegel recognizes that i mean i'm not sold that i haven't
seen those moments in the text yet like i'm sold that one can do that reading for sure i mean i to be
honest i haven't i haven't seen it fully either like the the stuff that i'm saying through Malibu
through Žižek like you don't you don't get the the the that kind of comprehensive um view at least
for me so far in the in the preface now maybe it's just because i'm reading through their lens like i'm
I'm like I'm just glomming on to stuff and I'm like oh that's perfect for my version of contingency
right like that's just that's perfect that's a little snippet that I can mobilize for my thing
right and again I mean that's where I mean I'm sort of operating with what what would be a
questionable distinction which is you know Malibu's Hegel versus Hegel right like I I'm making a
distinction there that uh so and I'm I'm generally speaking willing to give your version of Malibu and
Zizek's version of Hegel like I I'm willing to kind of defer to that but I I feel like I'm constantly
having to do the work of deferring because Hegel's not giving it to me well here's what I would here's
what I would say just provisionally um Nathaniel's coming back um I think that their version is the
most interesting for me but they they and even they wouldn't say this you don't just get to throw
out the other versions of Hegel like those are all part of the either the historical trajectory or the
kind of appropriative complex of of his text so you Habermas's version of Hegel is the democratic
Hegel um you know Ko Jeff's version of Hegel is the sort of Nietzschean Hegel um but like so they're
all trying to do something different but they're not rejecting those other interpretations you know
the version we're getting from Nate I'm sort of reading it through that lens of the Zizek Malibu
version and um but yet there are all these moments where you know he clearly is delineating
some other path as being an inferior one to his which again given the thinking that shouldn't
actually be necessary or relevant right like um and so I'm I'm sort of saying like I buy that one
can do the reading of Hegel that we're that we're really operating under and like really and and that
if you can say like well hold on a second he couldn't really mean this kind of dismissive thing about
other perspectives because their moment their moments like any other moment um but he doesn't seem to be
aware of that right like he in terms of the writing that we're reading I haven't seen that in the text
we're reading I've seen that in a way of reading and again I realize I'm making a distinction between
for instance Zizek's Hegel or Nate's Zizek's Hegel and Hegel um and which is a questionable distinction
um and and I certainly say like that's a more interesting I agree with like it's a more interesting
reading to read it another way um and I'm very very comfortable with that but I still am not really
getting it from Hegel um I I just you know like for instance I mean the idea sinks into edification
or insipidity again I mean the what started us into that thinking was I said you know because
Nate had brought this up of the critique of essentialism in Hegel and a couple of times previously and
I said like you know if this is essentialism I don't see any problem with it because he's effectively
saying if essence is thought as this kind of static self-present thing that's a bad thinking of essence
uh that essence has to be put in motion you know that that in order for it to become actual
and I'm like yeah if if you think uh essence the essence of anything as being sort of developmental
and self-alienating and self-overcoming then that's an interesting version of essence you know and
and one that what why would anyone have a problem with I mean you would all I think I would also say
it's a complete reformulation of everything that I've understood the word essence to refer to which
is the static locus of being that is the core and what he's saying is the static locus of being that is
the core happens in movement it doesn't happen in a place it doesn't happen by just the disporting of
love with it itself right it doesn't happen in a proposition for instance um so that the in it so
that that's abstract universality and if it's going to be to itself that it has to include in
this case he says distinction between the essence and the form the form has to be part of uh of thinking
that process right and this is where like it's been helpful for me to not I mean or at least because
he's very clearly referring to other um other positions but it's been helpful for me to de-emphasize
that um just because the way I I read 19 is that like this you know this whole process would be all
too insipid if it didn't do this other thing but it's got to do this other thing it's this is going to
happen right so I mean I like I like that better I mean I like that better because it's it's like if it did
this other thing it would be but but it can't so right yeah it only got up to this point but it's
always going to go further here and I'm going to always tell you what the further is right yeah I
mean essence has to be a movement here it's it's the movement of the dialectic for Hegel and I mean
it might be reductive but like for me I've been thinking it like it might be too easy of a of a
proposition but essence is the process of essentialization like so that's why some of
These these terms are are are so central for Hegel like transcendence we have God here is because the
purchase of those figures on the movement of thinking that right there's still power there
so it's like it's when when we try to simply step away or extract transcendence or a God figure or
essence out of the system we are then not recognizing that movement in our own thinking
um and that's where I would say uh that the the kind of vulgar version of negation where you are
kind of just simply erasing or uh appropriating the other where he's where he's saying no to Spinoza
right the the thing that you're uh bristling against yeah again this is a very generous interpretation of
that but I think that basically Hegel foregrounds that uh kind of ruthless simple
reductive form of negation because again because it still has purchase like like so fascism is
articulated in Hegel because of its ostensible like inescapability but that's a representational
argument right like I mean in other words what you're saying is well it's the case and so therefore
he has to account for it as opposed to like the very sort of performative or productive notion
of thinking where it's like well maybe it was the case but it doesn't have to be the case and so
that's the sense in which like I mean that that is saying I have to account for things that are
fascism is something that is well okay but I mean as a formal tendency I think his point at
at least what I'm getting out of it is that fascism takes many shapes and forms um but that that that
tendency when we think we've gotten past it when we think we're being progressive you know for
instance when we think we're not being reactionary uh we still are in some sense so that that fundamental
kind of fascistic movement has to be a component of of engagement or of interaction for Hegel um so
the the he's not going to shy away from the the simple critical or negative gesture
right because for sure that's still that's still the way we engage in some it's like
he but it's not I mean that's the problem is that I mean I I can accept that I don't mind I mean
certainly Nietzsche is you know relentlessly negative but it's not for Hegel it seems like it's the only
move it's not like he's not shying away from it it's that he doesn't have another one
right he he doesn't have a sort of non sort of dismissively negative orientation or and as you're
characterizing or Žižek particularly it's the same kind of thing it's like you know it's it's kind of
one trick of dismissiveness or inadequacy every you know everyone's a failed version of me
you know yeah I mean but the the me the the me is also failed though like I think that's maybe what
distinguishes them from someone who also they don't really offer a program fine but I mean I don't see
I haven't seen that here I mean I get again that's where like the claim that yeah is is also a failure is
the thing that I'm accepting on uh okay yeah yeah sort of future because I don't see it here to me
what I see here sounds like it sounds like the Habermas that I'm sorry you might have missed what I'm
saying and and I'm not saying Habermas is Hegel I'm just saying one of the things that I dislike
about reading Habermas in the Philosophical Discourse of Modernity is the way in which
everyone he engages he says you know they fail to get to communicative rationality because of
difference or because of power because of whatever else in other words the upshot for me whenever I
read this is it's just it's just a discourse on how everyone fails to be me and I just find that so
fucking unbelievably uh egocentric and to me this reads like that right this reads like how everyone is
just not able to be me poor poor you know fuckers yeah right I mean I I get that and I don't think
that's simply wrong or anything but again to not to push the generous reading but there are moments
maybe even in the in the preface but where he articulates subjectivity is the failure of its
actualization right so if subjectivity is kind of the term that he's running with or self-consciousness
or one of those basic well we can talk about if they're synonyms or not but if it's always a failure
then Hegel himself certainly doesn't get out of that that mechanism or that movement um but again
that you're right I mean you're right in the sense that the narcissistic tendency is there it's just
that I think the way that Malabou art uh says it is that it's bait required for you to kind of engage
the the dialectic as a whole it's like Hegel why would it be required bait I mean I I get that it
would be bait yeah I understand right right but but the idea that it would be necessary or required bait
seems like yeah that that's presupposing a necessary component of subjectivity that I think is not
necessary I mean why would it be necessary that dismissiveness negation has to be the only way
That you can engage otherness again, uh, for me, for me it's like again this is going to sound reductive
but like foregrounding the fascistic tendency is warning of its inescapability. It's not I don't
think it's saying like you can't be you can't do something productive or ethical. I think it should
right it's warning you that basically like when you think you're doing something else
you're probably still doing a version of this. So this then is a giant anti-humanism
I mean again this is why I want to not read in the specific targets and read this I was gonna say
like right we should read this much more impersonally right that I I mean I I again I think that you're
right that you know he's writing with Spinoza and showing and the others in mind but let's here's
what a generous reading is why not name them and why not articulate them more explicitly and why
deal with this and at the level of such generalities and I mean to me it is because
the labor of the negative this is I think with our very first meeting you know the distinction between
negation and failure is still important to me and I don't see the kind of failure um uh that um
that you know results in Hegel as much as you all do. I see where it comes from but what I see is a
an impersonal movement of the negative that and this is where I'm willing to um to take
Nate it's generous reading and say um you know that the negative will have to move through Hegel as
well like that insofar as Hegel is Hegel is not the culmination even by even from what I've read so
far Hegel was not the culmination of this style of thinking he is perhaps at at the forefront or he might be
driving along world spirit in sort of like taking a notion and and concretizing or really I think he's
just like dealing more with it with a simple idea and setting up the stage for it to be concretized
but that has to be self-alienated right if you're going to take anything that he's been saying
seriously um so yeah I mean I just I I so let's just read this impersonally but okay but the problem
I have with that claim is that it effectively says in the dialectic between general and particular to
particulars don't matter that it's not a dialectic right like I mean so because that's what you're
effectively saying right is that you're saying the particular points through which he moves are
really not important and it would seem to me that if you're if you're really going to emphasize this
sort of self-alienation you've got to say the particulars are very important and not everything
you know well I mean they only matter insofar as they effect the self-alienation
they only matter in relationship to their their uh a component in the general but then I mean again
like then the general or the transcendent or whatever becomes I think yeah I mean I there is
some use I think in guessing the figures that he's after but I get your point Nathaniel like
I think we were actually wrong about one of them last time like where we were talking about Schelling
I don't think like I was like that's probably not Schelling you know what I mean because I was like
I went back to it and I looked at the dates and I was like well Schelling was a contemporary so the
what he was setting up actually seemed like something different I mean who who cares if we're wrong or
right really I mean the way that the logic mapped out kind of worked in the moment but you know if you
looked at it historically it probably wasn't correct but I mean you're you're both pointing to one of
the central issues for me and for the generous readers of Hegel which is that that tension between
the general in the particular like is the formal tendency the the the rule all is that kind of the
god term for Hegel and I think in a in a certain sense yes it's just that that tendency transforms
itself it aufhebt itself constantly but there is like a component of it that remains the same right
it's preserved and repressed and preserved and transformed and repressed and right it's but his
notion of form like I'm not buying the same that's totally the same I don't think that the general in
particular is operating at the same level as the um at form and content because like like form seems to
me to be very imminent here that right oh yeah for sure the notion is sort of like imminently emerges
out of the simplicity of of the last paradigm and expresses its own end like that's all imminence
there's no transcendent there's no transcendent form that is governing that the only and this
is where I just think it's so easy to subtract as I was saying in the last episode that there are these
two notions of telos operative here and one is the imminent one where every paradigm expresses its own
end and then has to follow it out expresses its own form but then there's the one that sees each of these
you know simplicity to complexity back to simplicity like it's keeping it on the trolley
Trap and it just seems so easy for me to subtract to that second one, and the only reason he doesn't
want to is that would lead to a header like a very scary heterogeneity, but when I read 19 here
I don't see a dialectic between the general and the specific. I see a dialectic between the imminent
expression of a form and its manifestation and the contents that it produces, and that's not even
and that's not yeah and that's not even the dialect is the dialect there's not even a dialectic between
those two things. The dialectic is still happening between the old and the new, right? And it's like
the dialectical opposition, like the self-alienation, is like the the playing out the for the playing out
or the materialization of of a form is the dialectical response to the thing that that this whole process
is self-alienating itself from, right? In other words, the playing out of of um relativism, to use the
example that we used last time, is like the the formalization and the materialization of relativism.
It's not, that's not where the dialectical and um uh activity is. It's between relativism and some kind
of essentialism. But wouldn't it have to happen but wouldn't it have to happen at both levels? So for
instance when you talk about um the imminent the imminent one, which is this sort of movement of
you know let's empiricism or rational or whatever that thing is, but that also is transcendent in
relationship to particular individuals that are working within those paradigms, right? Like so
in other words the imminent transcendent thing happens at every level. There's you can't just pick
imminence because that imminence is transcendent in a different sense, right? Like so so the thing that
you're calling imminent, you're saying transcendence is the overall general world history, imminence is any
particular movement developing itself. And I'm saying okay let's take that imminent, the particular movement
developing itself romanticism whatever the fuck we pick, but within romanticism then you've got particular
individuals who are doing their imminent telos, right? So every time you pick imminence it's a transcendence for
something else, right? So you you don't you you can't just separate off I mean that's how I mean to me
that's how it works is that it's always a coupling it's never the thing that we're calling imminence at the
level of the the particular formation is transcendence at the level of the people who are living during that time
right? Um, but I don't think it's transcendent relationship to the same thing is that the
particular people that are living it at that time, like that the transcendent link there is back to the
form of of the paradigm, right? So it might be so like you know I might be in the process of romanticizing
myself, right? Right? Um, but that that relationship isn't too like it doesn't have to be the individual in
this case any particular individual living in the early 19th century doesn't have to have a necessary
relation to the movement of world history even though they do it at some level they can simply have a
relationship to the the paradigm in which they're in which they're living so they're a moment of that
paradigm and that paradigm is a moment of of world history you know so you always have that movement
between eminence and transcendence at every point so even and you'd even say even at the level of the
individual like the particular person so you'd have an eminent and transcendence relation for a particular
person for a particular you know nationality for a particular epoch for a particular you know paradigm for
a particular for a particular world history, right? In each of those levels you're going to have an
imminent and transcendent dimension is that? Yeah, and for for Zizek that minimal gap between like
transcendence and imminence and the inaccessibility of that, right, of that movement, that's what how Zizek
articulates like the real or the thing in itself for Hegel. So it's not a positive order of being that's like
beneath or behind the subjective edifice. The real and the reality in itself for Hegel is that crack
you know between essence and appearance or between formalization and then the content or the effects
produced by that movement. So it's like there's this minimal sort of temporal gap that Zizek articulates
between some of these terms between eminence and transcendence and it's the inaccessibility that's
basically the motor of the dialectic, right? So it's I mean again so but another way of saying that then
is non-identity you know becomes the becomes the engine um hence why negation but again that's where
for me I get like there are other ways of thinking not you want multiplicity you want multiplicity
they're just other ways of thinking non-identity there again I mean for me the argument is not
multiplicity is the right thing. The argument is why is negation have to be the only voice
right? Like well it doesn't I mean it doesn't have to be I mean that's why we get to lose
you know it's not right I mean it's like Hegel does in some sense have all the answers but you
Can still challenge it's not like you have to just you can't you don't have to just be like well
this is all there is like you don't have to make that move i kind of like to do that but
well but my my my reservation is that i feel like in accepting certain variations on that move i'm
buying a lot of things that i'm not sure that i want to buy and and that that really is the reservation
and frankly i mean for me it does right now still kind of come down to i gotta buy serious i gotta own
seriousness and i don't want to own seriousness as the sort again not that i'm not serious a lot
of times or not that i don't like it you know but that that's the only monologic way of not being
insipid and edifying
so